oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys we have with us Mr Jason
Cheney
I heard you've been
secretively coming
should we fire you you know what
yesterday I came early you did you did
I'm late so you average yeah averaged
out oh yeah did you just [ __ ]
scissored no I don't like when people
wait for me I feel like that's like I
used to have dreams where I wake up and
I'm like oh [ __ ] I missed a client
session or something like that like I
have I have nightmares like that what
the [ __ ] happened today because none of
your [ __ ] businesses why'd you walk
in so mad though no because especially
over 30 minutes late yeah that was a
pretty long one first first shots at 10
15 baby I was 15 minutes late all times
at 10 per Michael's email no big deal
yeah right Call times at 10 first shoot
times the door Dean because of Steve but
go ahead used to be 10 45. but this
morning I left the house at 6 30 a.m to
go train clients and then usually I get
here by like 10 ish you know 10 15 ish
you know it's really anyways
but on time for the first shot okay I
mean all right not me but there was a
gas leak my wife calls me at 9am saying
hey there's a gas leak in the house it
smells really bad of gas and I was like
[ __ ] so I had to leave the gym you know
she wasn't lying
because she don't lie about stuff like
that even though she lies about other
stuff she wouldn't just be waiting at
home with lingerie like oh yeah oh
that's a good gas leak and then she
farts yeah that's a Ty leak that's a
title that's like best case scenario but
okay you don't ever go like how do you
know this [ __ ] gas leaking
I just ask her yeah just keep giving her
[ __ ] no well I just was like she sounded
worried so I was like all right this is
like some big deal I'm trying to derail
my days yeah they're trying to [ __ ] my
day up so I go home and I'm like oh it
smells real before I get to my front
door I can smell gas oh no so it was
really [ __ ] bad so I'm like I'm
pissed hurting are you dangerous huh is
it are you dangerous
was dangerous
are you endangered dangerous
I like I wasn't danger
that was dangerous man wait where was
where was Tiff this whole time was she
just in the house she was in bed she was
sleeping why was she in the house she's
in her lingerie
in bed sleeping I left early and then
she calls me at nine she opened up all
the doors and windows and stuff like
that but it went back to sleep no no she
was like cleaning that she was she was
about to leave the house when I got
there so when I got there she's like I
gotta go she had to go pick up her mom
or something in her lingerie yeah I know
crazy in a in a [ __ ] coat but I was
like all right dude [ __ ] okay so I had
to call the gas guy I was like kind of
pissed ready because it smelled so bad
it was like the worst gas like I've ever
smelled and then I look at the oven and
it just on oh my God we haven't used the
oven because your boy got a kasori air
fryer [ __ ] 10 quarts amazing so I
don't even I don't even use my oven so
did you turn it off but that works it
wasn't even on like so it was just it
was mechanically on yeah but the dial
was off and the oven was like the light
was on because it's like you know like
this that's not a gas leak that means
someone left it on no we haven't touched
the oven bro I'm gonna tell who touched
it then nobody Cooks in the house nobody
well I cook in the house your dog
touched it no no it we didn't touch it
someone touched the knob the nozzle you
got me a [ __ ] liar dude no I we
didn't touch the we didn't touch the
[ __ ] thing no because when the gas
guy came here he was like oh this is a
faulty lost dangerous this is a faulty
night it was good I was almost it's a
faulty knob yeah we haven't touched it I
swear to God it just opens by itself oh
I wish maybe you're [ __ ] happy
millionaire with your cool ass [ __ ]
oven call me a [ __ ] liar man I am
just turned on by itself
make this Cop come off by itself how
about that oh shut it off
by itself
no I'm telling you because we have it we
got this air fryer I haven't even
touched the [ __ ] oven because the
oven for the stove that my leg so the
stove that my landlord gave me there's
no there's no like temperature control I
have to buy like the internal that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] so it's kind of a
[ __ ] janky ass oven that's why I was
like I'm gonna buy air fryer because I'm
gonna use that instead anyway
so the fact that it was on in the
morning I was like what the [ __ ] is
going on how do you turn it on actually
like a [ __ ] knob Jason knob on the on
with other knobs
you probably yeah
I'm just trying to I'm just trying to
take some notes take you back on this
[ __ ] guy's bit okay no I was
wondering
so it doesn't make sense right oh he's
just fat kicking her ass [ __ ] bite
him I guess I don't know where I am
right now it was Twitter baby not but
the gas guy came and this dude was like
I can't find the leak and I was like bro
huh I was like dog there's a [ __ ] you
smell the gas dog like you kidding me so
I was getting kind of mad at the gas guy
for a little bit not not mad but I was
getting frustrated in my head I was like
he's dangerous this [ __ ] better
find it while while he's checking all
the things the oven turns on again oh
[ __ ] it's a ghost right I don't know and
he goes oh oh that's what it is I was
like yeah [ __ ] I'm trying to
tell you is this the Home Alone house or
the [ __ ] oven turns on yeah running
in the [ __ ] room no but yeah it
turned on and I was like what the [ __ ]
is this goddamn stuff so I'm I was
living and it smelled so bad in the
house so I was waiting for the guy to
come and he fixed it and then he turned
off the valve and I emailed my landlord
and I was like yo you guys better get
this [ __ ] yeah fixed you better get
this [ __ ] janky ass stove out of here
real question is where were you
Halloween night
Halloween night why why what's up who
followed you home what Spirits yeah if
there's oh there might be ghosts I don't
think there's ghosts in the baking
spirit I don't need to go to my house
because wifey Burns sage and [ __ ] that's
crazy good thing she was a burning sage
that day I know that's what I'm saying
it would have exploded that was what I'm
saying he was using incense last night
one Candlelight and that's why I was
[ __ ] that's why I'm kind of pissed
because like dude that's that's some
really big so pissed because I would be
so scared well I'm mad because I'm like
yo don't give me this janky ass stove
like get this [ __ ] stove out of here
the guy turned off the gas it's all good
but I just was like upset because it
smelled so bad how come you didn't call
the landlord first huh how could we
didn't call it I sent them a [ __ ]
email this morning how come you didn't
call them first what do you mean because
aren't they supposed to get their guys
to come fix [ __ ] and then they they are
but when it's a gas leak you've got to
call the gas company uh you got to call
the gas company right away and then they
have protocol of like hey make sure you
don't turn on the lights
oh you can't even turn on the lights no
bro you can't
so I was like staying on my sidewalk and
from my sidewalk I could smell the
[ __ ] gas that's so much gas and then
yeah so I was gonna have to pay for that
that's what I'm saying I was like you
guys better [ __ ] not bill me for this
league it's like the homeless guy like
that's why I don't all homes
can you cut up keep cut off all gas
supply to your home because you don't
even use it well I use it for like you
know stir frying heating right yeah
heaters heaters
oh you just don't use the oven but you
use a stove and yeah like I use the
stove tops I just don't use the oven
because the air fryer does just as good
and then like I used to use the broiler
but I think the stove was just kind of
janky so I'm just kind of pissed like
yeah Whirlpool no it's not even I don't
even know what the [ __ ] brand it is
Sears I wish it was Whirlpool it's
probably good Brad you wish it was I'll
probably have to go seriously buy a new
[ __ ] oven but because I'm like I
don't what did your landlord personally
say in in like was he apologize they
haven't they haven't emailed me back but
I've been battling them not battling
they're actually pretty cool they just
got a new washing machine for us because
it broke so I was like all right because
it's whatever and that's cool so like
for the most part they're really cool
but sometimes it's like Yo dude this is
a [ __ ] very dangerous thing you know
especially that like tip was sleeping
that's massively dangerous you know what
I mean like that's a big [ __ ] and the
oven just turned on by itself like what
the [ __ ] is going on is it old
probably yeah it's it's I'm imagining
your house looks like one of those San
Francisco houses and it's in the ovens
from 1932. no it's not that old it's
just say Pasadena it's the same thing
yeah but but yeah that was my morning
how was your guys this morning [ __ ] dude
I didn't smell gasoline fart that's for
sure you're still getting fired though
for like
no excuse like I there's no excuse for
being I don't like I don't like excuse
me I like JK it's a fair company so you
know thank you guys for my last day and
um it's been an amazing ride
um I actually need another person here
because it's gonna be hard I gotta go
back soon you want to repair you wanna
you wanna sit here you just got
re-ironed man really I guess I know
you're re-hired now I'll check [ __ ]
water balls all over this goddamn Place
make sure the the carpets are so that
was impressive I've never seen a [ __ ]
Cactus fly that's crazy crazy yeah and I
was that was seagulled so you have to
call the gas company it's not like a gas
maintenance guy you got to call the gas
California Gas Company and say yeah yo
you got leak up in this [ __ ]
someone's smoking cigarettes they're
gonna bolt my house how should they
arrive within 30 minutes that's sick
better than the police we're low-key
okay so 29 minutes to die yeah what the
[ __ ] yeah what what that's why you have
to leave the [ __ ] place so you
reported gasly and then sometimes how
did you know all this protocol yeah
because I have homies that worked at the
gasket well it's like you call the guy
yeah
I don't even know where to call that's a
really practical answer look at the
guests you guys don't got homies that
we're going to go nope I got a homies at
Edison when I first moved in when I
first moved in the gas guys couldn't
come out because it's like usually
around October at least in this area
October to December is when they're
always busy so a lot because all the gas
leaks be cracking and unlocked open the
gasoline people [ __ ] with the
fireplaces and [ __ ] fireplaces like the
the old school
um heaters oh the range yeah like the
like the tall one like the furnace ones
so people like a lot of times the gas
guys are going around town or whatever
and they're probably under staff like
[ __ ] everybody else but the hack that
people would tell me is like you report
a gas leak from like your furnace if you
want to get it turned on and then people
will come and turn it on for you and be
like oh it's a gas leak but oh can you
turn this on for me and then they'll
turn it on the the heater for you so
that's like one thing that people would
say but whenever you want a gas guy to
come out you just kind of report a leak
that's what that's what people say on
the internet but for the most part if
it's a real gas leak they have to come
out within 30 minutes because it's like
a liability thing oh wow so [ __ ] but
this is this is like a serious now
everyone's reporting their furnace
problems as gas leaks and then the
people with real gas leaks have to wait
longer now yeah yeah but even then even
like the gas guys like they told me the
same [ __ ] they're like just ask for a
gas just say you know your gas leak will
come out and we'll [ __ ] do that it's
crazy that yours is a real legit high
risk situation your house could have
just become a yeah yeah it was [ __ ]
ridiculous we would have been doing JK
news about Nick
[Laughter]
yeah so that was uh that was my morning
it was uh pretty eventful but your boy
was and then I drove like a [ __ ]
demon over here but it was traffic
wasn't that bad I don't have another uh
emergency does
um does that make you feel like there
might be other things in your house that
could be equally risky because if
they're gonna let that slide maybe the
[ __ ] bathtub's just gonna shoot into
the sky to be fair our landlords our
landlords are actually pretty cool
they're pretty cool but what about the
building the coolness they kind of look
like you dude they look like me is the
building like older is that why no it's
just like
I I really think it's they
they cheaped out on the [ __ ] stove
because they they furnished the place is
this the first time it happened though
in like years that's the second stove
we've had out of three years we've lived
there oh two stoves in three years
that's kind of a weird stat so what kind
of stove are they buying the stove yeah
that's what I'm saying the fir the first
one stopped working and I was like hey
we need a new stove and then is that a
Kenmore
actually no it wasn't even like a name
brand that I've even seen before it
wasn't a General Electric
I think it was General electricity those
are going under ever since China bought
them that sounds like a really strange
malfunction though like I know when
things stop working but that's starting
to work by itself that's like a weird
and also too I think there may not be
like a pilot or something so that's why
the gas leaks you know what that happens
oh yeah is it just like well sometimes
the light comes on without turning on
well the pilot is the spark yeah
dangerous Jason you're right so
sometimes some up in some old school
ovens have a pilot and then the gas
feeds and then it heats up the [ __ ]
thing oh yeah what my suspicion is that
the pilot was out and that's why the gas
was leaking because if it it would just
be the fire yeah I mean the thing the
little flame that like lights the oh but
I don't [ __ ] know I have no idea I
don't know anything about it do you just
turn off the valve in the bathroom since
you're never going to use the stove I
told the guy I was like hey please and
he said yeah we have to and they have to
put like a warning notice and then they
have to put like they have to write a
report you can't turn off yourself they
got to deal with the tool or something I
think you can do it by yourself but I
also I'm like I don't know what the [ __ ]
to do time I didn't know it was coming
from the stove I thought it was also
coming from the meter because I was they
were asking me is it coming from the
meter and I was like I smell gas by the
meter so they were like all right stay
clear of the [ __ ] home are you gonna
go home today yeah so when I was there
the gas guy was there dealing with all
the stuff and then he told me yeah it's
because he has like a little meter thing
and he checks all the potential gas
leaks and then right when the oven
turned on again there was no sound and
then it sounds like rare like coming
from the [ __ ] meter so that tells you
that that's where the gas leak is you
want to hear the sound again yeah
it's like one of those things where they
measure radiation at Chernobyl kind of
like that's exactly what they sound like
or the guys on the [ __ ] beach did you
yell at your landlord no I just sent him
a very strong email but it's not his
fault though is it no it's not his fault
but I just want to let him know he's
fault Jason the stove is [ __ ] up yeah
and if it's a third broken stove within
the years like that sounds like he got
some refurbished Salvage stoves and then
he got a lemon stove they usually send
the handyman and the handyman is the
humming Miguel he's cool [ __ ] I told a
story about how I was texting Miguel on
accident and I was texting my wife and I
was like yo Miguel's so [ __ ] cool I
love this dude and then he texted back
and I saw that I texted Miguel on
accident and I was like I'm so sorry
Miguel and he goes at least you had
something nice to say but usually
they're they're really cool but it just
you know so happens that they just
cheaped out on the stove what are you
gonna do dude renters problems like
tonight you're gonna sleep in the house
yeah it's fine because the the the leak
is thank God that uh Tiff's not like a
candles person or something
oh but usually but not in the morning
huh good thing she's not awake and big
kind of person yeah when she waked up as
a [ __ ] hit a joint or you guys don't
got [ __ ] in some dry ass sheets yeah
you know in the middle of the night if
you pull your [ __ ] out of the dryer
don't use the drying sheets sometimes
you go
and it's she just text me we'll see what
the update is
no okay it's all good still alive yeah
how does it feel like you almost blew up
your whole [ __ ] house that's so crazy
well yeah that's why I'm a little like
on edge I'm like God damn it dude like
that's a serious thing because you know
people can [ __ ] they die from that
[ __ ] they just be sleeping and they just
yeah what do you do to get off edge
hang out with you with the boys dude
hang on that JK a little bit I haven't
jerked off in a while dude oh is it
because it's November yeah do you
sometimes Watch Adventure though huh do
you sometimes want an adventure what do
you mean it's kind of cool if her house
blows up that's true it's a good story
for Jake for oti you don't I kind of how
much better of a story would have been
if my house caught on fire for OTR we
would have been I would have pulled out
the tapes right you and tip were out of
the house that might be yeah if no one
got hurt and you're like yo my house
blew up I would have got the tables and
we would have gone on site set up on
your lawn and then done the JK news with
your house in the background it's still
on fire yeah and it wouldn't matter
anymore because you're not gonna live
there but honestly the reason why I'm
mostly upset is because I was gone and
Tiff was in the house while that [ __ ]
was going on yeah that's true that's not
[ __ ] good at all did you ever did you
go why didn't you [ __ ] call the gas
company that's what I would have said
why didn't she well she why are you
calling me foreign
did you turn anything on this morning
and I was like no dude I was 6 30 I
[ __ ] you know that smells artificial
what you mean they put that in there the
methane in there so that if it's leaking
you know versus if it was the natural
smell you just wouldn't even smell dude
Bart's kind of a scientist dog he's got
Gas Buddies this dude knows all like
these random facts very practical things
though about science they make it smell
so bad they should have made it smell
like strawberries can we leak all the
time
I went back to Seattle
and you see yourself
that's you
walk by with this fanny pack in the film
I bet you dude you're turning it on and
off like 50 times a day they got safety
you gotta like push enter oh yeah it's
like it's like bottles caps for pills
yeah but that's why it's [ __ ] weird
and then when the guy was looking
through he was checking everything and I
was like Hey do you find any where the
league is he's like not yet we were
there for like 15 minutes I was like bro
it's the [ __ ] stove I told you guys
that [ __ ] was on and then now it's off
so I feel like I'm a crazy person
because I'm like it's the stove it's not
me and then I come here and then Bart
[ __ ] gets in my face about it and now
I feel like I'm crazy dude
check the nest cam oh it is a stove if
it's been on it'd be warm so that's what
I'm saying he was taking all this stuff
out and I was like dude it's warm you
can feel it right and he goes
he goes nah and I'm like this dude it's
his first day he gives him a break but
afterwards when he saw it he was like oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah and I was like
[ __ ] guy you're right but he was he
was really nice you should be a gas guy
too yeah yeah
who are the top suspects so there's you
Tiff the guy you beat in Jiu Jitsu at
that tournament do you guys have you
have an animal like a cat we don't have
an animal at the house the baker's ghost
well I think it's [ __ ] weird it might
be just be a ghost like he said though
you know those stoves you gotta like
push them in and turn and stuff like
that I still had to get the stoppers
because my cats would still be able to
turn it on so you have to get the
stopper that stops IT from being able to
push in as well and you put these little
put these little rubber guys in there so
I kept leaving the stove on and then my
pots would turn black and I was like yo
I gotta do something about this [ __ ]
cause I can't be leaving this [ __ ] off
when I delete when I leave the house and
I and I searched and there's knobs that
you can replace that you can control on
your phone whoa but maybe it's not the
knob though maybe he's like just like a
wiring it's a knob because I leave it on
and I cook something and then I leave it
on and I leave the house oh you
accidentally left it yeah it's the
wiring in here
you're selling my dad dude my dad would
always leave [ __ ] pots on and we come
home and it's like the pan is like a red
hot dude
the house is like covered it's like a
Excalibur sword by that time but that's
a blacksmith bro
remember
one ring to rule them all
there's gotta be a better way like
technology out there instead of me
correcting my behavior I'm just like
there's better there's got to be
something better to fix this problem
it was expensive but you could switch
the knobs and the knobs turn yeah and
then they turn off for you that's how
that's how it is he's on his phone he's
like dude I got this [ __ ] thing that
turns off your phone from far away
this knob on my oven will turn my phone
off over there
no but I'm glad you're okay dude glad
everything worked out so honestly I
still feel a little like I know yeah but
you know what that's good training for a
[ __ ] adult life you're doing well
yeah
foreign